hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie today we make a footer so
we've completed well pretty much
completed the header or the app bar the
the drawer which is our side nav and now
we're going to move on to the footer I
like to start with those things because
they're going to be pretty much
consistent across the entire site so I'd
like to go with those first that gives
us more time to look at it you know kind
of perfect it you know it'll be tested
more just by us looking at it you know
constantly and as we're building out the
rest of the site so the footer is
probably the least important of those
three components a lot of people won't
even see the footer but it's still nice
to have it's a place where you can put a
lot of the links that you know
especially with higher education there's
a lot of regulations and things so you
know we'll put privacy policy and
different things like that you know down
there at the bottom you got to have them
there but you don't really want to waste
you know prime real estate at the top on
things like that so basically we're
gonna make a footer that matches the
colors to the University and has space
you know for all those links at the
bottom maybe like in a dress it's nice
to have an address that I think it's
pretty common that people will look you
know at the footer for contact
information so that's the plan today I
do have a sore throat so I've been
taking zinc lozenges and they cough
drops and things so hopefully I have a
cop traffic copter up in right now so if
I sound weird sorry it's the cough drop
but I want to be able to get through the
stream
without my throat just getting crazy and
me losing my voice the weird side effect
is though my taste buds like totally
don't work
I just tried to drink something and it
didn't taste at all like it normally
tell you so anyway
Miroslav says drink more tea actually I
did have a cup of tea before the stream
as well but the tea bag was really old I
just found it laying in the bottom of
one of my one of my drawers here and I
thought why not I'll try it and so the
tea was really really weak but anyway
alright enough about my health problems
and beverages let's get started
what did I do since the last time all
harsh attack Harshit added end to end
testing so we have some new testing so
if you have this repo running locally
you'll see some new options for testing
and I'm getting a weird okay let me show
this now let me change my view here and
show you this this error that I've been
getting and see what you all think about
it so check this out I keep getting this
error now it's pretty self-explanatory
it actually says check out this github
repo to add this so I haven't added it
yet I did check out the repo it seems
pretty simple so right now it's not it's
not breaking anything it just brings up
you know a million warnings like oh
there's a lot of warnings here so you
probably need to fix that I'll try it
you know doing what it says in this repo
first
and then see how it goes
I also think that I fixed the problem we
were having where the the styles just
went all crazy and our fonts were we're
just really huge so I went in and just
there's an example in materialized beta
github repo for using material UI beta
with next so I went through the the
appropriate files in that repository and
then compared them to our files and I
went through line by line our files are
were almost identical there were really
just two lines that were different so I
changed those two lines to make them the
same you could check it out it's it's my
the last commit that I made I changed
some some lines in there so since I've
done that the problem has not happened
again but I certainly haven't tested it
thoroughly so we'll see if I don't see
the problem you at all for the rest of
the day I'll be pretty confident that
the problem has been fixed but it did
seem like there are other people who are
having that same problem or similar
problems so I guess it's somewhat common
all right OOP so I wanted to show you
here's the footer that we have now this
will give you a preview of kind of what
it's going to look like so we're gonna
go with this green color I don't usually
like having giant blocks of the green
color but I think it's it's okay with
the footer somewhat appropriate will
have that gold border so it'll kind of
match you know what we have going on
here you know at the top here will have
the same thing also I changed the
background image so we've got the same
background image for for a long time not
just for this project but I think did we
use it for home tests we did actually
just not showing up so one point we
using it for that too so anyway I found
this cute little pug dog and I might
have to change it cuz it's just so cute
I just want to look at it all the time I
don't even want to code anymore
but anyway I thought it would be fun to
look at my my wife's parents have a
little dog that looks pretty much just
like this except their dog is way fatter
than this dog but it reminds me of that
dog alright so here's what we're going
to do we'll have our regular green color
here and then a slightly darker shade of
that color down here for kind of like
the the sub footer I don't know what
you'd really call it we're gonna have
our copyright stuff and then all these
links for all the kind of legal stuff
that we need and I think I'll just I'll
keep this set up for now and if we want
to change it later we can but it would
be good if somebody happens to get to
the bottom of the page then you know why
not give them an apply button and donate
button again since that's what we that's
what we expect to be the main actions
that someone would take and the main
things that we want them to do when they
get to this site primarily apply but
then also potentially donate depending
on whether they're prospective student
or not all right so that's the plan
this was done I believe we use material
UI for this so we can't just grab all
the code we can grab some of it I'm yeah
some of it like but basically the
content I guess I'm pretty sure material
UI does not have any type of pre-made
footer at least they did in the last
time I checked which wasn't that long
ago so these are the components we have
so far probably what we need to do
well we ought to do is maybe just use
their their grid system to build this
out so that's my plan if anybody you
know has has used material UI and and
has done something like this and those
of a better way to do this you be more
simple let me know otherwise let's start
out by checking out the grid see layouts
let's check out this grid so we're going
to be using a grid component and
there we go so we'll have these um let's
see we can oughta lay everything exactly
[ __ ] available space okay so I guess
we'll go with this full width that seems
like that will fit our use case yeah
let's just copy two classes we have one
yeah we're good
just grab this grid we'll just grab the
whole thing and then we'll get rid of
what we don't need
okay
let's go over whoops almost forgot to
set the timer so we're gonna do we're
gonna break up the stream in two
25-minute periods
that'll be broken up by five minute
periods in between so 25 minutes of code
five minutes of question-and-answer
we'll try to get two sessions in today
and then I'll do question and answer
after that also I see there's a lot of
activity in the live chat so I'll come
back to that if you've asked a question
already
after this 25-minute session I'm going
to come back and go through everything
that's already been in the live chat and
I see in general a lot of you're just
saying hi and hey everybody actually
someone ever even says say hello to us
from Brazil so I will do that eh
hey everybody in Brazil everyone thanks
for watching okay
just copy that and we'll go over - we
definitely want to make this its own
component so let's go here in components
and make a new file
I'll call this footer js4 now I'm going
to put everything in this footer
component but it's possible that we may
want to refactor a bit and extract out
you know some of what's going to be in
the footer component and it the liberal
in this stream extracts some of that out
and make it into its own components
we'll see how large it gets usually I
don't like to have really large
components if if it's avoidable and
usually is avoidable all right so let's
actually let's just grab something here
this is really big let me grab the
drawer is that smaller yeah this looks
smaller let's grab this your first yeah
let's grab the drawer and let's paste
that and then that'll save us some time
and now let's get rid of all this stuff
and paste that in and actually might be
able to just keep grid here so let's
let's take out drawer as well see what
it'll look like we'll just read scary to
some of this stuff and get rid of footer
and let's change this to footer I don't
think we need State but we will need
we're gonna put one function in here and
I'm not gonna do it yet we'll save it
for a little while later toggle droney
toggle drawer we don't need open and
let's see missile nested function we
don't need any of these let's grab it
sue any really search icon button
divider we get rid of all of these and
this and that and we're not actually
using the prop types right now I don't
think we'll have any props to be honest
with you well I guess we'll still have
the classes did we even have that in the
prop ties before you know we didn't okay
so we don't need those either
great so now this is looking a lot
smaller which is nice and let's see what
kind of grid we need so we'll need I'm
sure like this so definitely we want
small let's change this to I'm assuming
this is a twelve column system I guess
I'll find out in a minute
so if it's a twelfth column system I
want to change this to the four columns
each on a small screen I just want to
get someone here so we can see most
likely gonna be adjusting this at some
point and then I would like this to be
twelve all the time and that's gonna be
our bottom our bottom bar there and then
we don't need any of these so all right
before yep that's what I want glasses
paper
oh let's get the Styles in there
you know what I didn't add that route
I'm gonna add that
let's add this route like we have any
example movie says class name class this
week
yeah let's add that in May we may not
need it but closer we get to the example
the less likely we are to have any
problems okay so not bad let's okay so
we do have some text in here I'll leave
that in there for now just so we can see
it that looks all right
so I'm going to save that and then let's
good or layout component and let's put
in below below this part we're gonna put
in our footer and then we need to import
our footer as well so I'm just gonna
copy what we have here for drawer and
then I can put in footer I'm gonna save
that let's see if we've done anything we
didn't import grid I'll see when I read
the live chat if anybody caught that I
thought I had everything okay so let's
see let's grab something here make it
easier
and we'll change this to grid and while
we're at it let's double check to make
sure you don't have anything else in
your paper
okay so we'll probably need to import
paper
it's a grid and paper and I think
that'll do it yeah okay awesome
so we have down here at the bottom full
width we have our three across here like
we wanted and then one below obviously
this isn't you know this is not how we
want it styled but it's just just the
first step in here so at this point we
want to do for sure a few things that
container that we put in if you remember
that that that div that we wrapped
everything in I'm kind of glad I did
that now because it'll be good to have a
wrapper component so that what we'll do
is that wrapper component will put our
background color of green that hash
that's 2 1 4 1 2 a the hex color we'll
put that as the background color on that
and then we'll put our border on that as
well of course we'll take out all these
paper styles we'll remove the paper
component completely we don't need that
and then at the bottom here we'll make
sure that there's nothing here no
padding margin anything like that so
this is flat on the bottom but on this
we'll put a background that's just going
to be black but it's going to be
transparent so it'll show the green
behind it but it'll darken it slightly
so I think that'll work so for now I'm
not going to worry about content let's
worry about getting the colors and the
positioning down then we can worry about
throwing in some of that content all
right we got 15 minutes to do this I
think we're definitely gonna at least
get that part done and then the second
Pomodoro session will probably be where
we throw in some links and in some of
that content okay so we're gonna get rid
of paper we don't need that
and we also don't need these styles for
paper but our roots now we're gonna put
a background color of and let me grab
let's grab this color here there we go
okay so we have our the color but I'd
like to use is already in our theme our
material you I custom theme so we're
going to use that when we do it like
that it allows us then to go back in
later on and we can change our primary
color and not have to go and change it
in every component works basically just
like SAS variables - I mean not like the
inner functioning of it but in terms of
being able to change it in one place and
have a change everywhere it's similar to
how the SAS variables are okay so we
have the background color there we go
and we're gonna give it a border
so and it's going to be
you know what I don't think I could do
it like this let me try it like this but
I'm almost positive I've tried to do it
before and it didn't work so let's try a
boarder top solid three pixels and then
where's our gold color thought I had it
over here style guide I have the style
guide open somewhere but I don't know
where it is so I'm just gonna open it up
again I guess I already had that already
using it in the app bar components I
coulda just grabbed it from there
and we need to remove all of these paper
elements here this and this as well okay
and see how that works for now let's go
with let's add one more style we're
going to say this let's call this sub
footer and that's going to be that
bottom footer and let's put background
background color here and let's go with
RGB a and we want two five five two five
two five five and then let's go with a
point zero point one let's see how dark
that gets us here okay and let's add
that to this bottom one here last name
glasses footer okay save that oh-ho not
bad check it out
okay so it looks like we have not not
perfect here but oh all right so we do
have some weird stuff going on we have a
little bit of a problem I guess with
being able to scroll over a bit so we'll
sort that out at a different time I
don't want to get distracted by that
right now it looks like so that's
affecting everything
yeah but not bad so we have a border so
evidently this did work I don't know
what I did last time maybe I'm
remembering wrong but looks like that
worked awesome the C sub back
hmm interesting all right well let's
just put in some some content just to
get an idea of how it looks so for now I
think I'm just gonna put in I'm just
going to put in some divs actually not
even that let's just put in some P tags
with some lorem ipsum in it and I have
one I used to have lorem ipsum that just
popped up
guess not alright let's grab some lorem
ipsum text
and I'm going to use bacon ipsum
let's see what that gives us
see we have going on here
so we have
goodness I put the the wrong hex wrong
colors it
I'm afraid to check the live chat and
see who called me out on that uh-huh
[Music]
let's try there we go
so I instead of doing black with a
transparent black I did a transparent
white so anyway I usually never do that
by hand
I always copy it from somewhere or use
the color picker and dev tools okay cool
not bad that's that's pretty much
exactly what we want
I could probably stand to go with a
little bit darker color here let's
increase this and do a 1.5 or 0.15 see
how that looks
I like that I like that much better okay
and that border looks very thin I'm
thinking it's not gonna work so it works
up here I don't want a huge thick border
up here and it works it's it's subtle
but that's what I want down here we'll
leave it like that for now see what I
think about it but it may have to make
that maybe just one pixel thicker
alright let's check my time here while
six minutes okay
alright well let's put in some some text
and so we could use the material UI
typography component so I guess let's
let's check it out so not here am i
missing this
there we go typography
alright let's check it out
okay so let's try to use typography and
maybe give it a what's the default the
defaults body 1 so we'll just leave it
blank so we get a default on there and
for color actually I don't even know
what our secondary is set at before what
we're gonna want this to be white
okay
so for now let's just go in and use
typography instead of these P's eggs
oops
it's not I wanted to do it like this
area
typography and then we need to bring in
typography up here
all right let's see if it works did I
miss something
I don't really see much of a change
let's see what
let's see what we can do here is you
should do some stuff on your components
well let's add a color here go to text
and let's go color
let's give it whoops okay
give it that color we're gonna go font
size 16 pixels
and so then on nice typography no just
on the first ones we're gonna get
clothes named glasses
you call this footer put it text all
right
see what happens now footer text whoops
always forgetting the commas here
okay awesome so we've got the way text
let's check yep we got our font size we
wanted 16 I might want to make that
bigger for the top section leave it
smaller down here I think I do I don't
know about you but that just looks
really small let's bump that up and 218
and see what it looks like yeah that's
that's better one changed the line
height as well
okay
all right cool we definitely need some
some padding right need some padding on
the sides top and bottom so let's do
that for here we can put this just put
some general
we need padding and we need our top
padding to be let's try eight first we
might have to go at sixteen so we're
gonna go eight and on the sides we are
gonna go to 16 and 16 and we're gonna go
16 on the sides especially because we
have that scroll bar to deal with and
then we'll do 16 on both sides B just to
be consistent and then the bottom I want
it to be zero for right now because
remember we have that section with a
different cut background color so we
don't want to add padding there because
that's going to push that section up and
there'll be a small stripe of our
original base color so we don't want
that so we're going to put the padding
directly on that sub footer so padding
bottom and that's where we'll have eight
yeah let's give it a pixel on the bottom
and we want to push it up push the
content up above it right so we have the
the padding covered everywhere else
except for there so let's do a margin
top and first we'll try out eight pixels
and we'll go from there right we want to
do a margin and not padding because we
do padding to up that would make the
entire section color included get bigger
we don't want that so that's why we went
with margin let's save that see what
happens huh okay so we we got a little
bit of this we get a little bit of what
we wanted but not not everything we
wanted so we have our padding here
so check out that padding whoa
and then our margin
looks like we already had some padding
one on there by default so maybe we
won't need to do that but I do like the
the margin all right so let's stop right
there because my timer is up I'm gonna
take a short break now go over some
questions in the live chat and then
we'll come back and we'll mess around a
little bit more with a margin and
padding so scroll all the way up I'll
try to get through as much as I can
there's quite a bit here in the live
chat so we'll see how it goes Jimmy says
hi I'm new hey how's it going welcome to
the welcome to the live stream and feel
free to ask any questions or put
comments in the chat I'd love to hear
your opinion on things
okay Jimmy it asks does does this dude
reply so not sure if you're still here
Jimmy sorry I didn't see that but I did
explain it earlier hopefully you stuck
around and got the explanation that I
will I do reply to things in the live
chat but during the the breaks that I
take to go to the live chat
I did try before to you know try to
monitor the live chat while I'm coding
and it ended up not being so good it
took forever to code anything and yeah
so I can't can't do that thank you for
everyone who's giving me suggestions on
what to take for my sore throat I really
appreciate that
everyone asked what operating system do
you guys use the code I'm on Mac OS
right now I almost exclusively use Mac
to code my servers are usually Ubuntu
Linux and I do have pcs at home but I
don't code on them often I I just used
them for gaming
okay horseshit asked about the end end
testing if it works on my machine yes it
did work so yeah it worked it worked
perfectly well with the exception of
those errors that were on there but
that's not due to the testing those
errors showed up before I merged your
pool requests so but the the end end
testing itself worked perfectly so thank
you for that hardship Brook said that
picture is the best the Doug yeah so she
cute though I want to like get rid of
this text now so I could see this dog
better
oh cool so a hard shot asks if we could
if I could demo the end and test and yes
so let's do that so I'm gonna go yarn
test and if you have the most up-to-date
version of this on your local machine
when you when you pull the latest make
sure you've one yarn to install all the
new NPM packages but then after you've
done that you can say yarn test and
we'll see our test running so those
tests past those were a unit tests now
this is our end-to-end test so you see
it actually did the testing in the
browser which is awesome and we can see
it even gives us timing in milliseconds
so really cool if anybody's interested
in testing you'll be learning more about
it or if you know about it and would
like to get some more practice you know
feel free to add to the test that we
already have on there and then as we add
new components if you'd like to write
tests for them you know that would be
very helpful
I'm still pretty newly testing so I'll
do my best to keep up to date when we
add new components but to be honest if
I'm really like if I have a lot to do
the testing is going to get put off
that's just I am working on a few other
projects right now so I may not be able
to put in the time that I ought to on
that
yeah Jesse says Jesse McIntyre says that
pic is awesome Phillip says I hope the
pig is production-ready Jesse says way
too distracting yeah as soon as I saw
that picture I knew like I have to have
this on it okay so it didn't get through
everything in the chat right now but I
will after this next Pomodoro session so
I took a note of where I'm at in the
live chat I'll go right back to where I
left off
after the next session and let's see
okay all right so we put in some padding
and things but it didn't exactly work
like I expected it to so let's check out
what's going on
is it disk I might have to pull this
over a bit okay so our footer
it's supposed to have alright I need to
do something else with this let's do it
like this let's take this and dock it to
the bottom and let's make this
fullscreen alright
so when I do it like this unfortunately
I won't be able to make this very much
bigger we'd never be able to see
anything
and also I realized that this section is
now covered up but I will do my best to
talk about what's going on alright so
what we have here that I'm I'm wondering
about is we should have padding left oh
goodness
it was my mistake I messed it up I'm
sure you all notice this already or my
idea all right
let's arrange this a bit better there we
go
okay so unfortunately I don't know what
happened to my brain for a second but
this is not how you do position so the
correct order is top right bottom left
why why I didn't remember that at the
moment I have no idea but that was our
problem so you can see now we have our 8
was at 8 or 16 yes 16 pixels of padding
on both sides here and 8 at the top at
the bottom our container has nothing in
terms of padding oh goodness I didn't
even think about this but we can't do
that right because then we're gonna have
these little spots here let's fix that
so here's what we need to do we have
this these grid items here we'll need to
put our padding
correctly into these we can keep top the
top padding here so let's do adding top
and how did that look okay I think we
can go 16 for the padding top so let's
do that and then we're gonna make let's
just go footer footer sections and let's
say padding for footer sections and
we'll give a we're gonna give them
padding of 0 for the top and bottom and
then for left and right let's give them
16 we'll see how this looks
it may be too much between sections but
it's worth a shot so let's put in here
and these grids so just those first
three class name we're gonna say classes
dot footer sections great
alright now let's see what it looks like
and I forgot my comma again goodness I
need to get like a little jar on my desk
and I'll like every time I forget a
comma I'll have to put a coin in the jar
and then it can go to like some charity
or something but then I'll learn my
lesson to quit forgetting
that didn't work like I wanted it to but
I'll learn my lesson to quit forgetting
the commas in JavaScript arrays there's
a grid item
oops you know what our padding is being
overridden
that's fine let's go with a margin
instead I don't think we have a margin
on any of these yet no no margin but
margins will work in this case so yeah
let's not try to fight what's already
there we'll just switch it up to the
margin No
all right let's try this let's try to
use what's already built in here
okay how about we'll do this and see if
this works instead of putting it on
these grid components whoops didn't grab
it all instead of the grid components
we're going to put these typography how
do we do this can I just do a comma oh
goodness
no I can't let's see what you do a comma
classes for their sections I think I can
do that
no I can't
oops
see if that works yeah there we go I
need I need to make it an array and then
it will work
okay all right awesome so we finally got
what we wanted that took way longer than
expected but it's not over all not bad I
think we're making pretty quick progress
and did I find it yes okay I found the
issue can you all see that here's what's
causing our he's literally at my face
like a few inches away from the screen
right now so I don't know if you could
all see that yeah it's right oh right
here in the corner the bottom right-hand
corner or our shadow right is not a
shadow but you know I guess our overlay
is extending out you know past this so
that's where issue is why we're getting
this little section on the side so we
definitely don't want that so why is
this extending out when all goodness our
grid our grids extending out as well so
all of our great items are extending out
and we don't want that
hmm
II
okay so it has to do with what's going
on here
all right let's re reload that just to
get rid of what I did
oh let's alright let's check out our
grid
it's the spacing
okay this is a problem here so this is
exactly what's happening let me zoom in
on that a bit
so you probably couldn't see this in dev
tools because the the it was too small
and I think it was covered up by the by
the video feed of my face but there's a
negative margin and that's how they're
getting this to work so it's the the
official width of this grid is 100% of
the screen plus 24 pixels and then
there's a negative margin all around of
negative 12 pixels so let's see not
using the spacing feature and
implementing it in userspace adding a
padding on the parent with at least the
space and value
adding overflow X hidden on the pan
actually if this works this will be the
easiest way let's try it we can try it
oops right here in dev tools so the
parent would be this so let's go with
overflow X hidden alright cool
that solves the problem awesome
so we're gonna add this here so our root
components our parent and we're gonna
say we're going to remember a comma this
time overflow X hidden save that and
alright so now we don't have our
horizontal scroll wonderful and we still
have we have going on here what happened
to our arts up
hmm
goodness
yeah I want to do this too all right so
I'm gonna take off the spacing or I
think the example said set it to zero
I'm gonna take that off as well because
that seems like it's complicating a lot
of what's going on here so let's check
okay good so our padding is now working
properly great okay okay great
okay that seems to work so so what we
ended up doing then is there's this
built-in spacing property that you can
use with the grid container component
and it was it was kind of messing up
what we were trying to do you know
manually with our Styles here so I just
got rid of that it's easier for me just
to work with the CSS or the CSS and j/s
directly then to try to figure out you
know what I'm what I'm doing here
because I know exactly what I want with
this footer component so I think it's
just going to be a lot faster to do it
like this all right let me check my time
seven minutes all right okay so let's
get some stuff here in this sub footer
and yeah that'll be all we all will do
it's fun or example okay yes we just
have a copyright in these links
so you grab this and for this I wanted
to put span within that this is going to
be it's the gate year and up here we're
gonna have get year this will be
what is it I always have to live this up
for doing that here already I think we
are
okay so we just need to get let's say
this const date today equals new date
and then we'll say they meet today
it's good fool year
all right all right let's see you that
way to again
yeah no it didn't work
alright let's see what comes up
so you can control used to
I would add idea
I'm still getting it
I see the race
I mean two errors Susan's FoodCorps sick
the first one
saying I'm giving it an invalid crop but
it's working
oh it's just a prop type thing
now this one
I'm pretty sure we've done this before
in react yeah we have right
maybe we haven't
why it's not
okay
let me just skip that right now for some
reason I'm just not seeing what the
problem is I'm sure it's just something
silly that I'm forgetting to do or doing
wrong
let's we need a little bit of padding
here
a little bit more than we currently have
let's see
adding bottom margins up thank you so
yeah we don't have any padding right now
so let's add some top and let's go with
eight pixels on the top good so we have
eight on the top eight on the bottom
it's pretty slim might have to increase
the padding a bit but I kind of like to
have it a little bit more slim I think
it looks nicer okay not bad so let's add
that padding on the top and that'll be
the last thing that we do for for this
dream in terms of coding let's see you
know when we need some padding on the
sides as well so let's go ahead and just
change our sub footer instead of doing a
padding bottom we're just going to do
padding and go with that top of eight
pixels and then left and right of 16 and
bottom of zero since we already have
padding on the entire thing wait did we
know we didn't are we getting that
padding on the bottom
oh I had it separately how did I have
that sympathies
somehow I had padding-bottom on there
I'm not sure how okay let's add eight
pixels then and then sixteen sorry
everybody I'm starting a little bit of a
headache so I'm just kind of I don't
know if I'm making a lot of sense at
this point but in general we're getting
done what we want to get done okay that
looks good we have our the right amount
of padding okay alright not bad so you
know we have you know let's just compare
a bit let me get rid of this and we'll
compare so we have them side by side
here this is what we are going for and
so that looks now forget content-wise
I'm not worried about content right now
but just in terms of design we basically
matched it right we've gone with a
little bit thinner sub footer a little
bit thinner of our our top border but we
have recreated that design now and this
was done with materialized framework and
now we've recreated that with material
UI so I'll bed
not bad for for two Pomodoro sessions
and especially on a live stream
everything takes longer on the live
stream okay so let me commit this so you
all can see all the code and you know
what I'm so sorry I didn't start the and
Rock server I completely forgot to start
it
my apologies for that
I guess I'm just I hope I don't get
really sick if I'm going to get sick I
hope I get sick right now and get it
over with
we have Thanksgiving coming up here in
the United States and then right after
that I have the to talk at November
conference so I wanted one or the other
I even need to not get sick it just get
sick right now and get it over with
all right anyway let's do a git status
and see what's changed layout footer
yeah that looks about right
good commit and I'm going to use the AM
flag to just combine it all under one
step git commit am I'm going to say add
footer components let's run although
it's s so now I'll on commit we have
what we had before whoa
all right okay those are just our no
more errors for a second I I got nervous
for a second okay so in addition to all
the stuff we had before which was our
unit tests and our Auto formatting with
linting now we have our end-to-end tests
that run so for now there's not that
much going on and I have a pretty fast
computer so it all happens quickly
hopefully it stays somewhat quick
although if we end up getting a really
large application at some point on a
slower computer that may take longer so
but at this point it's entirely
manageable and now I'm going to push
this up to github awesome so now all the
code is available to you at the github
repo the links in the description at
this point I'm going to try to go
through all the questions and comments
and the live chat I'll respond to to all
the questions as best I can
if for those of you maybe can't stick
around for the Q&A session thank you so
much for watching I really appreciate it
and I will most likely be back tomorrow
around the same time assuming my my
sore throat doesn't get any worse all
right so I left off here let see left
off in in a discussion between a few of
the live chat participants so I'm going
to skip through that okay Brooke said
that keyboard shortcut he used is super
useful so the one where I selected the
texts let's go down here so I would
highlight something and then hit command
D or ctrl D if you're on Windows and it
highlights everything that's the same
right so it's kind of like doing a find
except it's a lot faster and it
immediately highlights that and then
it's I think it's called multiple
cursors and then you can see I can go in
and tab over or type things right and I
can type in three places at once not
it's very useful it's not as powerful as
doing a you know finding replace but if
you only have a few things that you need
to change it's faster than doing a find
under place so normally if I have like
less than ten things that I need to
change I do the ctrl D or command D the
multiple cursors otherwise I'd be able
to control fine but super useful I
remember first time I found out about
that it was like blew my mind it's like
wow this is the coolest thing I think I
found out about it on will Stern's
YouTube channel
it's learn code Academy and that was
it's just it looked really cool when I
saw him the first time
and yes you says hello hey ash you how's
it going
and I in is here she says hey hey how's
it going thanks for watching also says
your project looks cool awesome I'm glad
you like it let me know if there's any
anything I could change with that to
make it look nicer
okay Tim as Jesse what CMS so what
content management system is the old
site using is the database behind it
public wondering if it can be just
migrated to something else and wrapped
into a docker container that's a good
thought as far as I know the database is
not public I need to double check that
on Friday I think this is Friday no no I
think it's next week I think next
Tuesday I'll have a meeting with some of
the people from the IT department and
I'm going to ask them more about the
database at that meeting the content
management system is called Ektron so
ekt ro n so I haven't come across many
people who have ever heard of it let
alone and worked with it I try not to
work with it as much as possible it's
it's not very user friendly at least the
way it's set up for us who knows maybe
there's maybe it can be better than it
is
but in its current state right now it's
it's frustrating for the people that
have to manage the content
yes--you says hey Jesse why don't you
install this package it's teletype it's
an atom package using this people can
collaborate with each other actually
that looks really cool I might have to
try that out
I'm not gonna install it right now on
the stream but that sounds like it would
be really cool to use especially unlike
some side projects I could see that
being really fun or a good teaching tool
that would definitely be a good teaching
tool I think my wife's learning how to
code when she finally gets to the point
where she sets up her own code editor I
think that would be really fun the
problem would be getting both of us able
to code at the same time I don't know
what I'd do with the kids but I that
could be really fun California boy asks
how long have you been coding I've been
doing front-end stuff for about five
years now the first year of that was not
really like coding it was just like
basic basic CSS changes to WordPress
sites and then gradually I got more into
things and so about three years ago I
started like very deliberately learning
more about JavaScript and getting more
into JavaScript and at the same time
being more in depth into CSS as well and
then for sure for the last two years
maybe a little bit longer than two years
I've been doing you know more with
JavaScript development and not reactive
first I did a lot of single page apps
with with job with jQuery and then I
moved into reacts you know over the last
year or so if you'd like to know more
about my journey to becoming a front-end
developer I go into more depth about
like what I learned and when I learned
it there's a video on my youtube channel
which i think is linked in the
description
I think it's called like how I became a
friend and developer or something like
that
but you can check that out and I think
it's only about 10 minutes or so but I
talk more about when I learned to code
and how long it took Michael says I keep
asking my son why he watched his game
walkthroughs on YouTube and now I
figured it out haha well that's cool I
never thought of this as comparable to a
game walkthrough but I guess it's I
guess it is you know now that you say
that that's kind of cool
Blake says hey guys what games do you
play it's a cool question I don't think
we've gotten this one before right now
I'm pretty much limited to mobile games
because I just don't have the time with
with four kids all eight years old and
under to really like sit down at a you
know computer or console to play things
so mostly some some games on mobile I
like to play games from supercell trying
like what I i have minecraft on on my
phone i play that the kids like to you
know to watch when i play that my son's
been getting into minecraft on the pc
but i can't i can't help him with it i
get motion sick when he plays it and
lately I've been playing Super Smash
Brothers with my son just a bit and I
have an old Super Nintendo that still
works and I've been playing Super Mario
RPG with my son as well I did get the
the newest version of StarCraft so
they've been remastered so it's like
Starcraft remastered I got that and I
never played it I just was so busy with
my react nanodegree course that had
never played it I actually connected
with one of my old friends from high
school and we were trying to get
together to play online but she never
worked out maybe I have to make a better
effort maybe
every Christmas break or something
anyway I'm kind of interested in what
games you all play if anybody are into
into video games and if so what do you
like to play
okay yes you asked what testing you did
so the yarn test yes so it's setup let's
go to the package.json for a second so
how should set it up that test runs our
unit tests and our unit test is gest
we're using Jess for that and then we
have a test J's file you know configures
all that and then also we're running the
e to e so the e to the e testing is
we're using mocha and then if you want
to so like all these are available in
the github repo so you can check out
runner J s and spec jazz anything this
duck spec J s so if you want to look you
know more into exactly what's going on
check those files out
let's see
Michael says I want a two-shot of you
and harsh it
all right I don't dude I don't
understand what you let me know explain
explain that please Michel yes you ask
are we using webpack what yes so behind
the scenes webpack just going here but
since we use next to scaffold things we
didn't configure webpack ourselves so
there's a web pack config going on here
that's just the default from next I
believe you can do some custom
configuration next now has a next dot
config file I don't think we're yeah
we're not using it but if we wanted to
do some more custom stuff than with our
web pack build and we could do that but
right now the default is working for us
ok I see Michael notice the comma thing
so thank you for noticing that sorry I
didn't look over at the live chat and
see Michael also said I thought margins
and padding's were completely different
they are different let me take a second
just to run through some margin and
padding stuff oh yeah let's let's check
this up or let's do this since we were
just working on that so I'm gonna
inspect this and yeah let's make sure
that we're not let's see if I can
increase whoa too big alright so let's
try this so this I think is a really
great demonstration right here in dev
tools of how margins and padding's work
so we can look you know we'll take a
look here actually it would be better if
we had something let's let's go up a bit
so when you have something with a border
it's it's better ok so right now this is
our container div for a footer and you
can see here's our border is this thin
gold line so our margin of 30 pixels you
see is is that orange area it's outside
of the border right and then here's our
border of 3 pixels in the
the inside of the borders are padding
right so padding is inside the container
right so it's inside the container
inside the border and it's between the
content and the border margin is outside
of the border so it's it's outside of
the width of the container and it's
between one container that's in another
so your padding actually will increase
the content so you see like the
background color extends to the padding
but margin is outside of that so your
background color doesn't affect that
okay so that's how margins and padding
work so that's why sometimes we go with
a margin sometimes we go with padding so
it just kind of depends if you're using
a div that doesn't really have a
background color you can kind of use
margin and padding interchangeably the
user won't even know because of you know
if you have no background color or you
know and all your divs that you're
trying to space out if you do have a
color though then it becomes a lot more
important as to whether you use padding
or margins if you just use padding it's
going to look like there's no space
between anything because that background
color is going to extend but if you just
use margin then you may not get like you
know like we have here where we have
some space between the content and the
background color right so it depends on
what you're going for but they are
definitely different
Blake said that teletype package could
be a reason for switching over to Adam
for me actually I saw on Twitter earlier
this morning that visual studio code has
come out with something similar where
you can I didn't check it out for sure I
just know what I'm what I read on
Twitter that you can collaboratively
code on the same the same document the
same new file that's what it seemed like
like I said I didn't check it out yet I
didn't try to use it yet but so
potentially Visual Studio code can do
the same thing now Michael also asked
what's the purpose of setting a margin I
kind of explained that but basically
like in this case we have a margin
because I want there to be space between
the footer and the content that's up
here but I I don't want the color of the
footer to be extended here so I want
this this white space between so that's
where you would set a margin at least in
this case that's why we set the margin
we could have different reasons for
wanting to do a margin as opposed to
padding Blake asks if anybody has built
a PC I built a PC it's been a long time
it's probably been over 10 years since I
built a PC I think it's kind of fun but
if you mess up like if there's sparks or
something you could really mess up all
your stuff so that part is not fun I've
done that before and ruin things but if
it all goes well then it is kind of it's
really fun you know to build everything
yourself
definitely not as easy as just buying it
or have a custom having one made but if
you if you like that kind of thing that
it it was fun
John asked is box-sizing border-box on
these elements actually I didn't check
that's that's kind of important though I
should have checked we do not have box
sizing
it's not making a difference let's look
at one of these interior ones yeah it is
border box on these grid components box
sizing border box yeah so the interior
grid components are border box you can
see I wonder if I can see if we get it
to change yeah okay look at this huge
difference we have depending on on what
we do with our with our box sizing so in
terms of our footer it's actually not
causing that much of a difference right
now but the rest of the elements on the
page are like huge different
okay Blake sorry your your comment about
with the length to the computer parts it
was hidden so I just unhidden so if
anybody wants to check it out at some
point towards the bottom of the live
chat
Blake pasted a link asking about what
would you all think about the parts that
he's thinking of using to build a PC so
nope says test it out Firefox quantum
and it's three times faster than Google
Chrome that's really cool and actually
has test results in a video on on the
youtube channel so let's check that out
if you're interested and thanks for the
info oh no shoot I'm sorry so Rick just
reminded me that when you do get with
the flag a.m. it doesn't add a new file
so my footer component did not get added
I I do this frequently I should remember
so let's do a get add now it's there so
now I'm going to do git commit and let's
say get Twitter add a footer component
for real this time sorry about that
everyone I actually think I did that
last week too and I didn't realize it
until the next day
alright now let's do I get push to get
up alright so now the footer component
will be there really sorry if anybody
tried to check out that code and even
more sorry if you tried to do a get pool
and get everything running and thanks
for letting me know about that rope
smiler says Firefox quantum is really
cool stuff I'm gonna have to check that
out then let's have you ever used Booma
CSS if yes what do you think about it I
have not used Bulma so I don't really
have any opinion about Wilma because I
haven't done anything with it firsthand
I remember checking it out at one point
but it's been so long ago I don't I
don't really remember what I thought
about it Rick says do you have tests for
JavaScript Java on public you need
github I think all our tests should be
on on get up let's see we have them yeah
we should have all our testing stuff on
github
Peter says hi Jessie do you have an
opinion on Linux and the fail of the
city Munich in Germany with it regards
no I I actually did not hear anything
about that so I'm I'm out I'm at a loss
because I didn't hear anything about it
so I guess I don't have an opinion in
general my opinion on Linux is I really
like it for running my servers on it
seems to be easy to work with but since
I don't really have any information
about the particular incident you're
talking about I'm sorry but I really
can't give you a good answer
newark says play racing games project
cars and others with steering wheel and
a bucket seat it's really enjoyable that
sounds really fun actually that's that's
cool
see David saw a Super Mario Bros yeah
yeah actually so I'm gonna share a
secret with you all and you cannot tell
my eight-year-old or any of my kids not
that any of you talk to them but I think
I may get my kids the new Nintendo the
Nintendo switched for Christmas so I
wasn't going to because it's expensive
and I don't really have the money to
spare right now but my son my oldest
Raphael who's eight he really wants it
and he's been so good lately helping out
with the baby and with his younger
brother and he's in cleaning he wakes up
in the morning before school now every
day he's been doing this he wakes up he
cleans the bathroom and then reads a
book for 20 minutes takes care of his
baby sister and his little brother reads
his brother a book just been super super
helpful
so he's acting like that and now I am
like man I gotta get him something nice
so anyway I just wanted to share that
with you all because I'm kind of excited
about it and I can't tell my kids be a
true and the surprise but if anybody has
a switch let me know what you think
about it I'm going to end the stream in
a minute or so so I may not catch it
unless you put in a live chat really
quickly but let me know what you think
about it is it worth it is it fun what
games do you like that you think would
be appropriate for little kids there are
there any games that I should definitely
stay away from because they're either
not appropriate or they're just terrible
games anyway let me know because I
haven't even used it yet so I don't
really know what's good and what's not
good all right
Alexandre says hello hey how's it going
thanks for watching
eric says inline styles in react yay or
nay I don't have a problem with inline
styles in react I use them occasionally
the only is if you need just one element
to have a certain style and you don't
plan on reusing it anywhere then I don't
really see the problem with inline
Styles at all if you find yourself using
inline Styles frequently then you
probably would be better off using
something else could be CSS nsj it could
be just a plain style sheet or any of
the many different ways to do CSS and
react
John says your son sounds like a great
person yeah I don't know what happened
just recently within the past couple of
weeks he started being super helpful I
mean he's always been a pretty good boy
but man he just like he just matured all
of a sudden it's kind of bittersweet
though like he's not he's not like a
little kid anymore he's you know now
he's he's way more mature and being
helpful so you know it's the party me
misses him being little but now I'm just
so proud of him now you know for being
so helpful so anyway yeah so I want him
to I want him to like show him how proud
I am I can say it to him but I think
he'll appreciate it much more if I get
him something nice I remember how
excited I was when I was about his age
and my parents bought me a Super
Nintendo I was just super so excited so
I think it'd be cool you know to see how
excited he gets and his his little
brothers his little brother and sisters
will probably be super excited as well
not the baby I mean she'll just chew on
the controllers but the other ones will
be excited david says that typography
tag sounds like something really
interesting yeah I haven't used it that
much but it seems like it could be
really versatile I'd like to learn more
about it so as I use it I'm sure I'll
pick up you know more of what it can do
and get better with it
rook says that's very nice of him those
things don't just happen so you and your
wife must be good at parenting I don't
know about that I tried my best out of
the way I figure you can't really know
whether you've done a good job at
parenting too till they grow up and you
see what they came out as right you know
at this point like they're still they're
still baking right you don't know
whether you've done a good job till so
the cookies are done baking and you
actually get to taste them right you
know so if my kids grow up and have
families and they end up being good
then I'll know that I have been a good
parent you know if they grow up and they
they're good people then I'll know I've
done a good job so until then I just try
and do my best
David says no problem but we keep the
secret thank you I appreciate that
smiler sass how old are you I am 32 so I
just turned 32 at the end of October so
just a few weeks ago and yes I'm 32 and
I have four kids I've been married for
10 years like 10 and a half years old
Blake got his hack tober shirt awesome
awesome
that's that's really cool I'm still
waiting on mine when I get it I'll let
you all know I'll probably take a
picture of it and I think you need a
sticker - I'll probably take a picture
of him put on Instagram so I'll be super
excited about that as well but anyway I
am at the bottom of the live shot now
I'm gonna offer everything and I'm
feeling really tired right now my
throat's starting to hurt again so now's
a great time to wrap things up all right
I got one more question list a trick ass
besides free code camp what sources you
all used to increase the needy skillsets
who has referrals YouTube videos I like
YouTube videos and just reading articles
tutorials documentation yeah so I guess
I could give you more specific things
I'm gonna do a video at some point I
know I've been saying this for months
but I'm going to do a video at some
point where I list kind of all my top
sources for learning how to code but oh
cool Blake says you get 5 stickers for
hack
/ or for the heck Tober fest awesome
looking forward to that okay so I'm
going to end this stream for real this
time
thank you so much for watching and for
all your contributing in the in the live
chat or your comments and questions and
like I said I'll probably be back
tomorrow probably around the same time
2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
if I'm feeling alright if I feel any
worse tomorrow I may end up just staying
at home so I'll let you all know on on
Twitter if I'm not gonna stream and I'll
put something in the slack channel in
the gaiter channel too otherwise I will
be back tomorrow and until then I hope
you all have a wonderful day